in the car park of walmart a long line
of frustration of anger
and bewilderment
america 2022 and in jackson mississippi
the state capitol they have no safe
water i mean it's a travesty that this
happening in this day and age but at the
same time when the infrastructure is
outdated these are the type of problems
that we have but for a while that you
haven't trusted your water there's been
water issues we don't trust this water
at all did you drink i mean before this
past two weeks would you drink the
drinking water
the tap water you wouldn't drink it no
after the governor is blamed for it
yeah cause he wouldn't
get the phone to jackson to help them
for 150 000 people it is not safe to
drink not safe to brush teeth and in
many cases it's not coming out of the
tap at all
his parents is older and we try to get
some help get water for her too and
she's 87 years old so no drinking water
is it coming out of the tap or not it's
coming out but it's very slow and but
you can't use it for anything
it was the flood waters from the pearl
river which crippled the water system
this past fortnight
but this isn't simply a story of storm
damage it's about much more funding
politics race in jackson 82 percent of
people are black a quarter live in
poverty well above the national average
it is a city that feels neglected and
forgotten like so many corners of
today's america
less than 36 hours ago at a news
conference a show of unity masked a
tricky relationship the democratic mayor
has been asking for more funding from
the state's republican governor for
years
what went wrong why is jackson your
state capital in this extraordinary
position well what i would tell you is
and i know that you and the press really
want to play the blame game and you
really want to focus on
pitting different people against one
another and that's certainly your
priority that's fine what we are focused
on is the immediate health and welfare
of jackson residents there will be
plenty of time in the future to play the
blame game and y'all can do all of that
you want to do you can do it in real
time if you want to but i ain't got time
for it the stark reality is that he and
his authorities have no idea when safe
water will return to this american
community neglected for so long
mark stone sky news in jackson
mississippi